[Musique]
Oui
1 sont tellement
ne répond pas
je t'aime
Style classique
le début
les visions
et déjà
deux
à travers un classique
être comme toi
[Musique]
avec lui
est
Oui
maintenant troisième et quatrième
c'est l'histoire
comme tour à tour ces dominicains
d'accord
nous améliorerons
Oui
bien
et nous voici
MDR
J'ai aimé que cela ait beaucoup de sens
et en peu de temps qui dit
Tout va mal
pour les deux
plus que dire
nous utilisons
Oui
et
Et le son
et il y a du bon
Oui
s
ciel
bien
Oui
ailes 6
sous son nouveau poids
[Musique]
ré
wakata
plus
[Musique]
ef
ré
[Musique]
Oui
sont maintenant formés comme le genre de
numérique zierbena quelque chose à mettre 4
et de plus
similaire portant masculin
s
à combien
et évidemment
décembre
est
Oh
Oui
on a peur des bildu ils ont des andins
s
un de mes
Il dit
camp
211 mine pour le stock
non
[Musique]
pour moi
plus maintenant
c'est bien
Oui
au Canada
à l'internat
arrivée des fournitures de classe
et ça nous dit ce qu'il ressent
l'action d'ajustement qui lisse
et donc
augmenter
m
nous regardons tous
[Musique]
classique
Toujours dans les yeux pour te dominer
liqueurs
ses pâturages de tampico
Merci
un
non
dans les années dont la mesure
ne vous contentez pas de donner des objets
avait une autre classe
latapy
le maximum
dans la classe
avant de
[Musique]
soutien pour accepter la même chose
à ses côtés
censé pour moi est une partie saine
lorsque
mettons un seul point aucun
Trame
ce n'est pas ça
un
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]